[Music]
welcome to the Joma show the show where
we give you tips and tricks on how to
land a successful career in tech now
today we have a special guest
well Yuko I guess first things first
happy Halloween do you have any costume
I'm still working on mine right now but
I am going to show on Tuesday on
Halloween night so I'm pretty excited
for that awesome yeah yeah I'm thinking
I'm just bringing this to the office
showing everyone and stuff like that but
yeah cool I guess I'll serve some short
questions just to see you know if we can
be friends okay so there's no right
answer okay but there's a right answer
if you want to be like that okay
hopefully I'm right Mac a PC Mac okay
good answer
iPhone or Android iPhone it was a popin
okay
favorite programming language Swift okay
that's okay cuz ur an iOS developer and
okay I guess what boss favorite editor
for your editor you know I have a love
and hate relationship with this one but
it has to be Xcode that makes sense yeah
we can you code like not on Xcode yeah
yes yeah yeah must be a lot harder it is
yeah cuz I'm all about the vim yeah
that's right you can code on vim but
then you don't get all the lengthening
yeah that's true stuff I think that's
why I'm not a iOS engineer I can never
do that okay okay what about this coffee
or tea mmm
I'm gonna say tea tea yeah nice that's
good
I actually don't drink either oh that
wasn't even a question
I like hint water you know what this do
you guys have this no we don't have that
sponsored by hint water we're like every
other tech company and that we have a
shit-ton de Lacroix what is not McCoy
it's like the it's like flavored
sparkling water is in the little hands
oh yeah yeah those are all right they're
kind of like hint but you know fizzled I
guess yeah cool cool cool so you are an
iOS engineer I am
patreon yeah okay yeah yeah
so yeah I'm uh Iowa's engineer at
patreon I've been doing Iowa's
development for about three years now
and I haven't done any other like types
of mobile programming but yeah I used to
work at Intuit and I worked on the
TurboTax and QuickBooks apps and now I
work at patreon I've been there for
about a year and a half now - nice um
but yeah it's really fun I like it a lot
wait so in Intuit were you an iOS
engineer also I was okay yeah yeah yeah
what about before done before then I was
in school and did you do any iOS
programming game took one class called
mobile programming where we made an iOS
app but actually even before that there
was a software engineering course that I
took where we made an Android app so
I've made an Android app before I'm in
an iOS app Wow so I used like Android
studio and when I came to Xcode and I
was like s code is so much cleaner great
yeah yeah yeah I guess one thing I
always want to know like how I even get
started with I wasn't like development
because I always wanted to make apps cuz
that's what that's what's cool now like
nobody uses like web anymore
mm-hm well like it's just so hard like
the first thing I pop up is like Xcode
and then it tells me to download all
these things I don't know what they are
mm-hmm and then I don't know if frames
is that something like I have no idea
right how do I even get started yeah
yeah so I always definitely there's a
lot of different things that you need to
learn in order to get started and so
that can be really intimidating for
folks when I first started doing iOS
development in that remote mobile
programming class we open up Xcode and
there are so many knobs that I was just
like panic it can't do it
and so when I got started thankfully
there's a TA that walked us through how
to use it and so once we understood how
to use Xcode it obviously become a lot
easier but in terms of the actual like
programming language Swift and Objective
C which people don't typically learn in
school as well as like all the different
you know patterns and frameworks and
stuff that you have to use it can be
really intimidating but thankfully
there's a lot of online resources like a
lot of other programming languages and
the two that I recommend for getting
started is one actually by Apple Apple
is really trying to get more people to
do iOS
that was part of the motivation for
inventing the programming language Swift
and so if you actually look up like iOS
tutorial by Apple there is a great
tutorial that teaches you how to make
your first app and it shows you kind of
step by step like where to click and all
those kinds of things as well as what to
code my second most recommended like to
actually I have three so my second one
is a website called Ray wonder like calm
ray wonder like it's a person that opens
this like website and he has a bunch of
writers that writes these tutorials and
the iOS tutorials are super super good
they again are step-by-step tutorials
and like here's what you need a code
here's what you need to do and it has
everything from like how do I even get
started to like here's how to use this
very specific framework to do a very
specific thing like road I don't maybe
you want to like use the camera to
detect if it's a fruit or if it's a hot
dog in Silicon Valley I watch it was
like jinyang goes like a developer he
may hit a app that can detect what the
food is yeah and then he does the demos
like oh it's hot dog but now when you
point out something else it just says
not hot dog and that's all I can do DC
this year who came out with like a RvR
jelly I guess err kid and like a are kit
like they basically integrated into
iPhone right and so they're doing a
bunch of demos there's so many
references to like hot dog not hot dog I
feel like something about the show one
yeah but yeah that's cool yeah so I
guess like you know background engineers
we have like some inside jokes you know
we talk about certain things are like
certain bugs that we encounter
frequently yeah are there any iOS things
that are similar
yeah my favorite yeah my favorite ones
are against Xcode uh-huh which is the
IDE that we used to do development but
Xcode is like like I think any IDE can
be really finicky right and so there's
two jokes running tricks that I like
love and one is like if we say to each
other like Oh have you tried cleaning
derive data and drive data is just like
this cache that the that X could use
this to be able to compile faster but if
something doesn't work then that's like
kind of jelly the first thing that you
do I think one of my top tweets is
actually in me mimei
that's my claim to fame on Twitter um
and there's actually my second favorite
one against Xcode is there's just like
Tumblr I forgot what it's called it it
must be something called like [ __ ] Xcode
souther sighs races it's like a text
message thread between yourself and
Xcode and so it like throws different
errors and stuff and you're just like
wait but why is it in there so it just
repeats the air it says all these things
that Xcode does that are you so annoying
but I loved that block so much that's
interesting it's like your favorite
editors Xcode but it's also like super
annoying yeah yeah that's that's
interesting yeah cool I guess I want to
know more like about you cool you know
yeah like for example yeah I guess just
tell me about your life story and yeah
we'll go to high school and college all
the secret dirt all right I want to know
everything all right we're gonna be real
vulnerable real actors tears cool so I
was born in the East Coast in
Massachusetts pacifically oh okay yeah
and I was really little when we moved
back to Japan my family and I assume and
we lived there for about two years which
part of Japan in Kobe oh yeah yeah it's
kind of near like koto Osaka area okay
is known like most commonly tied to Kobe
beef oh yeah Bryant yeah yeah so we
lived there for like two years and then
we moved back to the states when I was
like three something so I barely
remember living in Japan but I lived in
the East Coast until I was about 10
living between like New York and
Connecticut and so like my early
childhood memories were like you know
having snow days my plane leaves and all
that kind of stuff
I was also like the only Asian kid in
school for a lot of the time so yeah yes
and then when I moved I moved to San
Diego California when I was dead
yeah San Diego you know dude
and yeah I went to middle school high
school there and then I went to college
at UC San Diego which was only like 20
minutes away from my house but I went
there and got my a degree in computer
science it's very cool cool yeah I guess
like one question because when I was a
kid like an elementary school I guess
you know I like things are
more engineering type but I just didn't
know for example I like building Legos
or I like playing this game called
Kingdom Hearts there's one small part of
the game where he could build a
spaceship and I loved that I played them
more than the actual game I love
building things yeah so what about you
like when you're a child like did you do
anything like that not really actually
I'm trying to think back and I couldn't
really like dig like I wasn't someone
who played with a bunch of Legos I also
wasn't I guess like one thing that I
think was common to a lot of life girls
might like that were my age was like
Neopets yeah beasts I used to play like
stock market in Neopets yeah I used to
trade like the marketplace like buying
sells things yeah and I trained my
little Kico I think that was a new pet
name to Kiko I'm like really strong and
I was like beating everyone in the
stadium yeah yeah my I always like mate
make sure like that my like Neopets page
or whatever I used to like make my page
look good with kids I think that was
kind of one of my first exposure is to
coding but also I was always like
getting free omelets
oh yeah Wheel of Fortune getting all the
free stuff and he loved it
yeah that was super fun brother than
that I think generally like I really
liked math when I was growing up - one
that's pretty mess and so like playing
computer games yeah I was that person
playing computer games that were like
math oriented even if it was like a
magic place you know in elementary
school they try to get you to play these
educational games yeah they're not games
games okay there's one game that I loved
playing that was like this like cash
register game form the amount with your
exact like which means and changes and I
was like this is so cool this is what I
want to do to fill an outfit dynamic
programming
maybe I did but I was just like this is
what I would want to do when I grow up
oh my god I like do this Massey stuff or
whatever like I love that game not even
a game it was right I love that yeah I
think yeah and then like as I became a
teenager
xanga was a big thing and also like
customizing your Zynga cage yeah yeah
and like even though a lot of it was
kind of like you know I didn't make a
whole template for Zynga for my page but
being able to tweak little things here
and there to make it look like you
wanted it to I guess it was kind of an
early indicator thing yeah that's your
like tweaking do you have to like cold a
little bit like at least like the hex
numbers we have colors and slow a little
bit like go you have to CSS and making
sure that we have the right color like
colors were kind of like the big thing
just a lot of like UI type things and
like moving like maybe I don't want this
here but I want it here and reading
through the HTML / XML or whatever it
was written in to do that yeah yeah
so I mean since you liked math so much
where you're like a nerd in school I
kind of was I was definitely like you
know in a second they're great you do
those like multiplication tables where
you sheets that you have to finish in
five minutes and I was like always the
first one to be done does have a
competitor yeah yeah but also like my
dad taught me why most locations tables
like earlier on so I was like got
parents too and there's like there's
like a Cantonese not a song but they
make you memorizing gasps Japanese tea
song so I'm actually pretty bad at
multiplication when we do like contests
like me against like a friend because
they would say it in French oh I have to
translate in Cantonese and then do the
multiplication yeah and then retranslate
it's the French oh my god yeah is so far
yeah people thought was super slow just
a language barrier
yeah the language barrier yeah yeah yeah
so what about what about high school
like who would you hang out with Oh or
do like math whiz yeah well so my school
was really big my high school had about
I think my graduating class was about
700 people so there are thousands of
kids in school so when there's that many
kids in school there's a lot like clicks
Range Rover if we had like the skater
kids and the jocks and the cheerleaders
and all the skater yeah oh yeah oh
really yeah we were more like rappers
and skaters oh that was
think that I don't think there are any
rappers at my school well I mean they
didn't rat they just like trapper I
would take skills that was really
impressive yeah impressive yeah no yeah
um so like I I was like I'm not like a
nerd nerd I'm not gonna be in like
science olympiad or anything like that
but I did play tennis and I did
Orchestra and I was also like yeah yeah
we can play I played violin oh nice a
very very Asian very difficult
instrument to play it is yeah yeah it's
it's really I had a lot of fun though
and my orchestra class was always like
very tight-knit and really small we went
to like definitely on everywhere for
festival and we went to New York when
year together to play at Carnegie Hall
which was like really really cool yeah
nice that was probably my favorite year
or gosh oh we're just like super tight
knit and we had a lot of fun our teacher
was like really cool too and so I think
I hung out with like the orchestra kids
a lot of the time but it was basically
like orcish your kids and like Speech
and Debate kids were kind of together
but really it was just like a lot of
Asian people at my school or like I was
hanging out with the Asian people at my
school and so yeah we tended to all be
in like the AP classes I guess through
like the Nerds
I mean just just like listen to yourself
[Laughter]
yeah yeah but yeah it was weird because
I was kind of like in my own little
bubble because it was such a big school
that I didn't I didn't ever feel like I
was like a nerd cuz like I would never
mix with like the kids who didn't take a
piece AP classes yeah those people would
call you Mary I had to keep my self
esteem somewhere you know yeah but yeah
I think I was like kind of shy I kind of
quiet but also like you know yeah I
guess I was kind of like a nerd issue
but this is what I guess you didn't do
any programming before college I did not
know I was like I thought computer
science was for like geeks and like old
white men yeah yeah just like my thought
of yeah I didn't really think the
computer science was for me like the way
that computer science and software
engineers are depicted in the me
yeah it's often you know like gamers or
like make sense yeah yeah none of them
like looked like me and I was also just
like I think that's a little too intense
for I'm not bad into computers it's true
I but you know what getting better yeah
like in media especially definitely all
like we have Coulter's like you know it
was very diverse back we got like
programmers now all of my secret about
board grammars I think it's just like
the nerdy people trying to
overcompensate a little bit yeah I mean
I try to be I try to work out and stuff
like that yeah but yeah I do think
there's a little bit of over constant
yeah yeah working out and being healthy
is a good thing exactly I'm taking
Soylent every day they could take care
of yourself so that that's fine that's
really cool I wonder really how the hell
did you end up in computer science time
if you didn't even want to be yeah I I
thought so when I entered college I
thought I was gonna be a chemistry major
because I was like chemistry is cool
there's like equations and then you do
experiments to prove the equations are
right and it's like whoa but I joined my
first class which was like quantum
mechanics in chemistry and you know it
was like freshman year Fall Quarter and
I was like what what of course what does
quantum me what does McKim yeah I mean
it just it was really intimidating I was
like I don't think I can actually do
this even if I did understand it and
then I tried neuroscience that also
didn't work out and I was just talking
to my floor mates one day at my dorm and
I was like I don't really know what I'm
gonna declare next like I'm kind of out
of ideas and he was a computer engineer
which is another form of computer
science on my school and I had just
taken a intro to logic class as part of
the philosophy department and that was
kind of like is really just like doing
proofs and stuff but just the logical
nature of it was like made a lot of
sense to me huh
and so I told my friend about that and
he was like you should try computer
science cuz literally it's just like all
logic and I was like oh there's a major
that's all logic and so yeah I took an
intro to computer science class and that
was the first intro to whatever class
that I was like I kind of like this and
I
I can understand a lot of it yes and
that's when it clicked it I was just
like that's it I'm doing computer
science and then it just like next thing
I know is in my second third fourth year
and I was a computer science major
mm-hmm yes I guess I'm now like I'm
curious what do you what do you do
outside of work assigning you to bang
now oh yeah you know cuz yeah yeah well
I was it I was gonna say YouTube because
it takes quite a bit of time I mean I'm
happy to do it but like you know it's
it's a solid hollaby now other than that
I think yeah I like like to hang out
with friends like I have a cat and a dog
and so I'm hanging out with them
watching watching YouTube I don't
actually have like side projects very
often for coding I'll like start I've
started a couple before but I haven't
fully like committed like two months to
one and so yeah I'm I'm like I think I'm
someone who actually was actually really
bad at holding a hobby I like play
guitar for like a month and I'll be like
I'm done
play like I'll go to the gym for like a
month and I'm like okay I'm done
and then I do it's just like I try a
bunch of stuff and then I like stop but
I used to like beat myself up over this
because I was like we can't do anything
but now I'm just like you know what
you're an adult and you can do whatever
you want and I'm like yeah I do what I
want with my time yeah do you want to be
in the highlights engineer like forever
like what's your fun girl and that's a
good question um it's something that
I've been thinking about really like a
lot recently until like a couple months
ago I was like I'm gonna be an iOS
engineer or at least a software engineer
forever I didn't really see myself going
into management or like being like the
own owner of a company or anything like
that
more recently I've been more open to the
idea of like becoming a manager so right
now my five year plan I think looks like
like I still really want to my skills as
like a software engineer I think there's
still some stuff there I'm like I feel
like I have pretty good solid like
coding skills now but in terms of like
architecting a whole system or owning
the delivery of a big thing like those
are the kind of skills that I want to
have more of so that's what I'm kind of
trying to do over the next
year and then like probably maybe
considering going into some sort of
management position maybe but at the
same time like if I feel that what I'm
doing in terms of like owning big
systems and big decisions at work is
really fulfilling then I might just keep
doing that but really I think like it's
fun to be evaluating at all times like
what I want to do with my life and like
YouTube has like really changed a lot of
that for me because I'm like I like to
have a big impact on other people with
like what I have in my brain what
experiences that I've had and so like
maybe YouTube is something I like really
leaning into as well so yeah I guess
we'll see but I think definitely gonna
stay in tech at least but really trying
to think of ways to like broaden my
impact and to help some of those things
that are trying to happen in the world
right now specifically like things like
getting more women into tech you know
also helping my company with their
mission to get more creators paid and I
would get a good you know living salary
for the art that they make yeah we'll
see that's nice nice super exciting and
yeah do you want to say anything to my
20 viewers sure definitely like Jonah's
like future series is gonna be super
funny I saw a teaser of it and it's so
funny so I'm really excited for that but
also for some self provo check out my
youtube channel hello my yuko and i'm on
social media ever also as hello miko so
come check me out cool yeah
thanks for watching and see you next
time don't forget to Like and subscribe
[Music]